OK. We are so far past this point now, it's hard to remember when the turning point was. But there actually was a turning point, and it was five years ago. What I'm talking about is you know those weird, mashup foods that fast food places keep gleefully launching into the world, like that pizza with the little hot dogs as the crust that Pizza Hut put out. Or Taco Bell did a waffle taco. Denny's put out a grilled cheese sandwich that inside was not just grilled cheese, but also mozzarella sticks inside the sandwich. Hardees put out a burger that had a cheese steak as the topping for the burger. Literally, like slices of steak and cheese and onions were on a burger as the topping.
好的。我们已经完全回不到过去了，甚至很难想起转折点是什么时候。但确实有一个转折点，而且是在五年前。我说的是那些快餐店一直乐此不疲地推向市场的奇怪的“混搭食物”，比如必胜客推出的那种披萨，饼边是一圈小热狗。或者塔可钟做的华夫饼塔可。丹尼餐厅推出了一款烤奶酪三明治，里面的馅料不仅有烤奶酪，还有马苏里拉奶酪条。哈迪斯推出了一款汉堡，顶部居然放了费城牛肉芝士三明治。真的，就像把切片的牛排、芝士和洋葱直接当成浇头放在汉堡上。
Anyway, so these Frankenfoods, or food mashups, or extreme foods-- there's no standard term for these yet in the industry-- they've been around for a little while. But there was a turning point. People in the food industry will tell you there was a turning point. There was a real turning point, this moment when they kind of came into their own. And it was five years ago, and it was a sandwich called the Double Down.
总之，这些“科学怪人食物”、食物混搭或者极端食物——业内对它们还没有统一的叫法——已经存在一段时间了。但确实有一个转折点。食品行业的人会告诉你，确实有过一个转折点。那是一个真正的转折点，是它们真正成气候的时刻。那是在五年前，是一款名叫“Double Down”的三明治。
KFC put it out. You may remember this. This is the one where fried chicken is the bread of the sandwich with bacon and cheese in between. And with the Double Down, one of the things that made it a turning point was, first of all, how extreme it was. But the other is, I think, it became clear that the food industry was in on the joke. Like, the Double Down, it was self aware of its own ridiculousness.
肯德基推出的。你可能还记得。就是那种用炸鸡排当面包，中间夹着培根和芝士的三明治。关于“Double Down”，它成为转折点的原因之一，首先是它太极端了。另一个原因是，我认为食品行业当时已经清楚自己是在恶搞。就像“Double Down”一样，它对自己的荒谬有着清醒的认识。
And whenever I see an ad for one of these things, I've wondered, OK, if these things exist, that means that somewhere, there's a room where people have to make these up and they have to debate, which one are we going to do? Which means that there's a list. And then there are guys sitting around a table. And somebody will bring one up, and they'll say, no, no, no. You know, everybody-- we've done that. Everybody's done-- that's so old. That's tired.
每当看到这些东西的广告，我就在想，好吧，如果这些东西存在，那就意味着在某个地方，有一个房间，人们必须想出这些点子，并且必须争论，我们要搞哪一个？这意味着有一张清单。然后有一些人坐在桌子旁。有人会提议一个，他们会说，不，不，不。你知道，大家——我们已经做过那个了。大家都做过——那太老套了。太让人厌倦了。
And somebody will bring up another one. They'll be like, sir, you've gone too far. You know, and I just was like-- I just wanted to know, like, what happens in that room? What is that discussion like? And fortunately, I work with somebody who also was interested, and she ran this down. Zoe Chace, welcome to show.
然后有人会提出另一个。他们会说，先生，你太过分了。你知道，我只是觉得——我只是想知道，那个房间里发生了什么？那样的讨论是什么样的？幸运的是，我和一个也对此感兴趣的人一起工作，她把这件事查清楚了。佐伊·蔡斯，欢迎来到节目。
Oh hello, Ira.
噢，你好，艾拉。
Hello. So Zoe, you went to the room where this happens.
你好。所以佐伊，你去了那个发生这一切的房间。
I did. I went to Saint Louis, Hardee's headquarters. Hardee's is the same company as Carl's Jr. And I brought you back a souvenir, Ira. In fact, there is a list.
是的。我去了圣路易斯，哈迪斯的总部。哈迪斯和卡乐星是同一家公司。我给你带了纪念品，艾拉。事实上，确实有一份清单。
This is of possible sandwiches?
这是可能推出的三明治清单吗？
This is possible burgers that do not yet exist, that are just in the minds of the people at Hardee's. And they wrote them down on this list.
这是可能推出的汉堡，但还不存在，只是在哈迪斯员工的脑海里。他们把这些写在了这张清单上。
How many burgers did they consider?
他们考虑过多少种汉堡？
Maybe 200 products.
大概200个产品吧。
Mhm.
嗯。
And before I give you the list, because I know you want the list, I just want to play a little game with you.
在给你看清单之前，因为我知道你想看，我想和你玩个小游戏。
Sure.
当然。
I'm going to read you two burgers. One of them is from the list. One of them I just made up. See if you can figure out which one is real.
我要给你读两个汉堡的名字。其中一个是清单上的，另一个是我编的。看看你能不能猜出哪个是真的。
OK.
好的。
First, the Napa burger, OK. Caramelized onions, Merlot glaze, arugula. And the Beyonce burger. Honey, and if you like it, you put an onion ring on it.
首先，纳帕汉堡，好吗。焦糖洋葱，梅洛葡萄酒釉，芝麻菜。还有碧昂丝汉堡。亲爱的，如果你喜欢，就给它加个洋葱圈。
If that Beyonce burger thing is real--
如果那个碧昂丝汉堡是真的——
It's genius.
那是天才之作。
That is genius. I just want to say for older people, there's a song by Beyonce, OK?
那确实是天才。我只是想对年长的人说一下，有一首碧昂丝的歌，好吗？
Everybody knows this song. You don't have to explain it to our audience.
大家都知道这首歌。你不必向我们的听众解释。
OK. So--
好的。那么——
So the Napa burger or the Beyonce burger.
所以，选纳帕汉堡还是碧昂丝汉堡。
I, mean the Beyonce burger sounds too good to be true. But I have to say the Napa burger, it doesn't sound like you would market a Merlot thing to a fast food customer. It seems like a completely different market, right? Like, somebody who's into Merlot is not at a fast food place buying a burger, I think.
我是说，碧昂丝汉堡听起来好得不像真的。但我必须说纳帕汉堡，感觉你不会向快餐顾客推销梅洛葡萄酒味的东西。这似乎是完全不同的市场，对吧？就像喜欢梅洛的人不会去快餐店买汉堡，我是这么想的。
Snob.
势利眼。
OK, fair enough. But I still think that Merlot drinkers are not going to want their fancy Merlot on a fast food burger, so I'm going with the Beyonce burger.
好吧，说得有道理。但我还是认为梅洛喝客不会想在快餐汉堡上吃到他们的高级梅洛，所以我选碧昂丝汉堡。
No. That is not correct. I made up the Beyonce burger.
不。那是不对的。碧昂丝汉堡是我编的。
All right. All right.
好吧。好吧。
OK. Do you want to do another one?
好的。还要再玩一个吗？
One more.
再来一个。
OK. All right. These two. 50 shades of pork burger.
好的。好吧。这两个。50度灰猪肉汉堡。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
OK.
好的。
好吧。
The burger itself is 50% pork, 50% patty, bacon aioli and whipped bacon on top. Here's the other burger, a clambake burger. Fried clams, corn salsa, Narragansett lager glaze.
这个汉堡本身是50%的猪肉，50%的肉饼，培根蒜泥蛋黄酱和顶部的搅打培根。这是另一个汉堡，蛤蜊烧烤汉堡。炸蛤蜊，玉米莎莎酱，纳拉甘西特拉格啤酒釉。
Well, they both seem totally unlikely. I'm going to go with 50 shades of pork just because the name is so great.
嗯，它们看起来都完全不可能。我选50度灰猪肉，仅仅因为这个名字太棒了。
That's the one. That one's real.
就是那个。那个是真的。
OK. So Zoe, so there's this list of all these burgers. They make this list. What happens then?
好的。所以佐伊，这里有这份所有汉堡的清单。他们列出这个清单。然后发生什么？
OK. So the next thing is that a team of executives will just vote up or down, simple vote.
好的。接下来是一组高管进行投票，赞成或反对，简单的投票。
This is just like their feeling about it?
这只是凭他们的感觉吗？
This is just based on the name of the burger, like what they think.
这完全是基于汉堡的名字，以及他们的想法。
OK.
好的。
And they whittle the list down to about 30. The next step in the process is maybe the most important because the next step is the taste test. And in the taste test, they make the burgers. They make the burgers that they imagined up in that room.
他们把清单缩减到大约30个。过程的下一步可能是最重要的，因为下一步是品尝测试。在品尝测试中，他们制作汉堡。他们制作那些在房间里构想出来的汉堡。
And a few guys sit down in a room. They eat the sandwiches. They discuss intensely. And they decide which ones will be real, which ones are going to move forward, actually be marketed, released into a few restaurants, tested on actual consumers and maybe go national.
几个人坐在一个房间里。他们吃这些三明治。他们进行激烈的讨论。然后他们决定哪些会成为现实，哪些会继续推进，真正被营销、发布到少数几家餐厅，在实际消费者身上进行测试，甚至可能推广到全国。
OK. And so this is the room where they figure out, Zoe, not just what the new foods are going to be but what they're going to call them and what story they're going to tell us to get us to buy them?
好的，所以这就是他们决定不仅是新食品是什么，还有叫什么名字，以及他们要编造什么故事来让我们购买的地方，对吧，佐伊？
Yes.
是的。
Because I assume, like a lot of situations-- and this is actually the subject of today's radio show-- so often, what's important is not the literal facts of what's real but how you tell the story, what you say about it. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. We have arrived at Act One of our show, where Zoe, you go to--
因为我假设，就像很多情况一样——这实际上也是今天广播节目的主题——很多时候，重要的不是事实本身，而是你如何讲述故事，你对它说了什么。来自芝加哥WBEZ电台，这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。我们已经进入了节目的第一幕，在这里，佐伊，你去了——
The room where it happens.
那个发生这一切的房间。
Tell us everything.
告诉我们一切。
First, the room. It's a kitchen, a fast food kitchen, an exact replica of what you'd find at a Hardees-- a charbroiler, a walk-in fridge, a fixing station, fryers.
首先是那个房间。它是一个厨房，一个快餐厨房，和你在哈迪斯里看到的一模一样——木炭烤架、步入式冰箱、配料台、炸锅。
Walk-in refrigerators and freezers.
步入式冰箱和冷冻库。
In the room are the men-- Brad, Bruce, Mark, and Eric. Brad shows off the kitchen.
房间里有那些男人——布拉德、布鲁斯、马克和埃里克。布拉德展示了这个厨房。
And this is kind of the engine of our restaurants because we charbroil our burgers and chicken sandwiches. So there's a charbroiler here that feeds--
这算是我们餐厅的引擎，因为我们用木炭烤我们的汉堡和鸡肉三明治。所以这里有一个木炭烤架，负责——
Picture a group of slightly nerdy science teachers-- Dockers, short sleeved button-up types. That's what they look like. But these guys are a big deal in their industry. They're trendsetters. For instance, meat as a condiment, these guys made that a thing. Like pastrami on a hamburger, or that cheese steak on top of the burger, that was in the early days of the food mashups.
想象一群稍微有点书呆子气的科学老师——那种穿卡其布裤子、短袖衬衫的人。他们看起来就是那样。但这些人在业内是大人物。他们是潮流引领者。例如，把肉当作调味品，这些人把这变成了时尚。比如汉堡上的熏牛肉，或者汉堡顶部的芝士牛排，那是在食物混搭的早期。
And Brad helped save another fast food company years ago, Jack in the Box. In 1993, maybe the most famous food poisoning episode in burger history, when E. Coli from Jack in the Box burgers killed four kids. Brad was in charge of the ad campaign that's credited with saving the company.
而且布拉德多年前帮助拯救了另一家快餐公司，杰克在盒子。1993年，可能是汉堡史上最著名的食物中毒事件，当时杰克在盒子的汉堡中的大肠杆菌导致了四名儿童死亡。布拉德负责了据称拯救了该公司的广告宣传活动。
We're going to start with breakfast items and get our palate warmed up that way.
我们将从早餐项目开始，以此热身我们的味蕾。
Today, Brad, Bruce, Mark, and Eric sit together at an industrial table, me too. We each have a place setting and a printed menu.
今天，布拉德、布鲁斯、马克和埃里克坐在一张工业桌旁，我也坐在一起。我们每个人都有餐具和打印出来的菜单。
We'll start with the cinnamon swirl French toast breakfast sandwich, kind of a sweet and savory combination for breakfast. A steak and egg biscuit after that. A mac and cheese Thickburger. I'm reading this now. Stakehouse Thickburger, big chicken masher, pepperoni pizza fries, and a Ding Dong ice cream sandwich for dessert.
我们将从肉桂卷法式吐司早餐三明治开始，算是早餐中甜与咸的结合。然后是牛排鸡蛋饼干。麦克奶酪厚汉堡。我现在正在读这个。牛排屋厚汉堡，大鸡肉碎，意大利辣香肠披萨薯条，以及作为甜点的Ding Dong冰淇淋三明治。
And they have to maintain an appetite through the whole thing.
他们必须在整个过程中保持食欲。
And the only way we can do it is these cups become very important. We use spit cups. It's like a wine taster or a coffee taster.
唯一能做到的方法就是这些杯子变得非常重要。我们使用吐痰杯。就像品酒师或咖啡师一样。
Except burgers. Just big, plastic to go cups full of chewed up burger. A wrapped up breakfast sandwich then arrives in front of each of us, the steak and egg biscuit.
只是针对汉堡。大大的塑料外卖杯，里面装满了咀嚼过的汉堡。然后一个包裹好的早餐三明治出现在我们每个人面前，是牛排鸡蛋饼干。
Steak and egg biscuit.
牛排鸡蛋饼干。
Bite, chew, spit. The biscuit, I'll say, incredible. Steak and egg, eh. Then, one by one, they each give their opinion.
咬，嚼，吐。我要说，那个饼干非常棒。牛排和鸡蛋，呃。然后，他们每个人一一给出自己的意见。
I like the idea of a steak and egg biscuit but I was expecting kind of more of a grill flavor.
我喜欢牛排鸡蛋饼干的创意，但我期待更多的炭烤风味。
Visually also, I thought I really wanted to see, like, the charbroiled character. And it looked a little more baked or boiled kind of beef. It didn't have the visual I wanted, so I think we've got some work to do. Mark?
在视觉上，我也觉得我真的很想看到那种炭烤的特征。它看起来更像是烘烤或水煮的牛肉。它没有我想要的视觉效果，所以我认为我们还有工作要做。马克？
Yeah, pretty similar.
是啊，很相似。
These guys aren't chefs. They're marketers. Their expertise is in, will America actually buy this thing, which is answered in the look as much as the taste. The next sandwich up, it's a large burger.
这些人不是厨师。他们是营销人员。他们的专业在于，美国人真的会买这个东西吗，这在外观和口味上都有所体现。下一个三明治是一个大汉堡。
Bacon mac and cheese Thickburger. Macaroni and cheese, and bacon bits.
培根麦克奶酪厚汉堡。通心粉奶酪和培根碎。
Again, chew, spit, talk. It tastes like a bacon cheeseburger, a good one, but it's weird because noodles.
再次，嚼，吐，说。尝起来像培根芝士汉堡，一个好汉堡，但因为有面条，所以很奇怪。
I'm not sure what to do with this one because it's cheesy, which is really important. You taste the macaroni and cheese. But overall, that's kind of a bland flavor. And if we put other ingredients on it to make it overall more flavorful, I'm a little worried we're going to cover up the mac and cheese because it's a subtle flavor. So I have no good idea for how to fix that. Fun idea, though.
我不知道该怎么处理这个，因为它有奶酪味，这非常重要。你能尝到通心粉和奶酪的味道。但总的来说，味道有点平淡。如果我们加其他配料让它整体更有风味，我有点担心会盖过通心粉和奶酪味，因为那是种微妙的味道。所以我对如何修复它没有好主意。不过这是个有趣的创意。
Same thing. I was struggling with it. I don't know if it's texturally, there's nothing that comes through with the macaroni. There's nothing that just makes it pop.
一样。我也很纠结。我不知道在质地上，通心粉没有什么突出的地方。没有什么能让它口感突出的东西。
I guess I was just wondering where was the hot sauce.
我只是在想热酱在哪。
Brad, Bruce, Mark, and Eric are pensive.
布拉德、布鲁斯、马克和埃里克陷入了沉思。
The hot sauce idea is kind of interesting.
热酱的创意有点意思。
It could actually be like a buffalo mac and cheese would be kind of-- yeah, that would be pretty cool.
实际上可以做成水牛城口味的通心粉奶酪，那会是——是的，那会很酷。
Tabasco might be too just vinegary, but buffalo might work.
塔巴斯科辣酱可能太酸了，但水牛城酱可能行得通。
I'm stunned listening to this.
听着这些我惊呆了。
Let's try it.
试一下吧。
Would we add it as a sauce or would it be blended into the cheese of the mac and cheese?
我们是应该把它作为酱料添加，还是混入通心粉的奶酪里？
Either way. I think I'd like the visual better if it was added as a sauce because then it would run like streaks through.
都可以。我觉得如果作为酱料添加视觉效果会更好，因为那样它会像条纹一样流过。
I am giddy with power, OK. I can't believe what just happened. Eric says he's going to do some more testing, bring the bacon mac and cheese burger back to the group with a buffalo wing sauce.
我被这种力量冲昏了头脑，好的。我不敢相信刚才发生了什么。埃里克说他要做更多的测试，把培根麦克奶酪汉堡带回小组，加点水牛城鸡翅酱。
There are a few reasons that guys like these are churning through these food mashups right now. One big one is fast food is losing market share to places like Chipotle, Panera, more upscale, healthier. So a way for fast food to compete is to go in the other direction-- downscale, greasier, sell to their core customers, 18 to 34-year-old guys. Though industry analysts told me it's nearly as many women as men.
像他们这样的人现在热衷于这些食物混搭有几个原因。一个重要原因是快餐正在输给Chipotle、Panera等更高端、更健康的餐厅。所以快餐竞争的一种方式是走向另一个方向——低端化、油腻化，卖给他们的核心客户，18到34岁的男性。虽然行业分析师告诉我，女性客户和男性几乎一样多。
And of course, there's money to be made in selling a sandwich that makes people want to take a picture of themselves while they eat it, but only to a point. The question is, will they eat it twice? The Double Down, you know the one where the chicken is the bun, as groundbreaking as it was, it didn't sell that great after people tried it once. Brad, Bruce, Mark, and Eric say it's too expensive to roll out a new product that you'd never order twice.
当然，卖一种让人们在吃的时候想拍照的三明治是有利可图的，但只能达到一定程度。问题是，他们会吃第二次吗？“Double Down”，你知道那个用炸鸡当面包的汉堡，虽然很有开创性，但人们试过一次后销量并不好。布拉德、布鲁斯、马克和埃里克说，推出一个你永远不会点第二次的新产品成本太高了。
This is a taco that's the talk of the town.
这是一个在镇上广受讨论的塔可。
What they want is something that food industry people say Taco Bell did better than anybody in 2012, when they released that taco whose shell was a Dorito.
他们想要的是食品行业人士所说的塔可钟在2012年做得比谁都好的东西，当时他们发布了那种壳是多力多滋脆片的塔可。
It's what one marketing consultant calls a marriage made in belly busting heaven. Doritos, the Super Bowl brand that helped turn America into a nation of chunky chip munchers, providing a nacho cheese flavored shell.
这就是一位营销顾问所说的婚姻天作之合。多力多滋，那个把美国变成咀嚼玉米片民族的超级碗品牌，提供了纳乔芝士味的脆壳。
The Doritos Locos Taco sold and sold and sold and sold-- $375 million in its first year. This is an amazing year for Taco Bell. Every sandwich that arrives on our plates here in Hardee's test kitchen, that is the goal.
多力多滋塔可销量一路飙升——第一年就卖了3.75亿美元。这对塔可钟来说是惊人的一年。我们在哈迪斯测试厨房里盘子上的每一个三明治，这就是目标。
All right. What's happening here?
好的。这里发生了什么？
Eric, tell us what we've got here.
埃里克，告诉我们这里有什么。
This is a new sandwich idea.
这是一个新的三明治创意。
The next sandwich is up.
下一个三明治上场了。
It's called Big Chicken Mashers. It's got mashed potatoes and brown gravy on it, some garlic pepper, onion straws, American cheese, and our big chicken filets.
它叫大鸡肉碎汉堡。里面有土豆泥和棕色肉汁，一些蒜椒，洋葱丝，美国芝士，还有我们的大鸡柳。
You really call it the Masher?
你真的叫它“大碎汉堡”？
Well, I don't know.
嗯，我不知道。
If we can't come up with a name, it's probably not going to sell. We run into that a lot where we have a great product, but what do you do with it?
如果我们想不出名字，它很可能卖不动。我们经常遇到这种情况，有一个很棒的产品，但该怎么办呢？
Careful. Hot out of the fryer. Might be [INAUDIBLE].
小心。油炸出来很烫。可能是[听不清]。
The Big Chicken Masher turns the taste test metaphysical, like actually. The issues that plague the masher are beyond its physical traits, because its physical traits are pretty good.
大鸡肉碎汉堡让品尝测试变得形而上学了，真的。困扰“碎汉堡”的问题超出了它的物理特性，因为它的物理特性相当不错。
I really like the flavors. It's like eating a Sunday chicken dinner. The mashed potatoes, the gravy goes really well with the flavor of that crispy chicken. I really like the crunchies in there. So I like the product. The idea I'm worried about. I'm not sure there's a market out there for people to eat mashed potatoes on a sandwich. I don't know if we can sell it, but I think anybody who bought it would really like it. But--
我真的很喜欢这种口味。就像在吃周日的鸡肉晚餐。土豆泥，肉汁和酥脆鸡肉的味道非常搭配。我真的很喜欢里面的脆片。所以我喜欢这个产品。但我担心这个想法。我不确定市场上是否有人会在三明治上吃土豆泥。我不知道我们能不能卖出去，但我认为任何买它的人都会真的很喜欢它。但是——
Would you say more about that? Why?
你能多说一点吗？为什么？
It's not enough for a product to taste good. It has to sound good or you'll never find out that it tastes good.
产品好吃是不够的。它必须听起来好吃，否则你永远不会发现它好吃。
It also has to kind of hold together as an idea. It can't just be five ingredients that we put together and it tastes good.
它还必须作为一个概念站得住脚。它不能仅仅是我们要放在一起的五种原料，然后尝起来不错。
What they're looking for is the story they're going to tell to explain why the weirdness makes sense. And it's got to be a pretty good story-- simple, punchy. Half ironic wouldn't hurt. That is just as hard as coming up with the sandwich. Here's an example of when it works. The product is a hamburger topped with a hot dog topped with potato chips. But listen to the story they tell about it.
他们正在寻找的是他们要讲述的故事，以解释为什么这种古怪感是合理的。而且必须是一个非常好的故事——简单、有力。带点讽刺意味也不错。这和发明三明治一样难。这是一个成功的例子。产品是一个汉堡，上面有热狗，上面有薯片。但听听他们讲述关于它的故事。
What's more American than a cheeseburger? This cheeseburger, loaded with a hot dog and potato chips, in the hands of All-American model Samantha Hoopes in a hot tub in a pickup truck driven by an American bull rider on an aircraft carrier under the gaze of Lady Liberty as she admires the most American Thickburger with a split hot dog--
还有什么比芝士汉堡更美国？这个芝士汉堡，加了热狗和薯片，在美国公牛骑手的皮卡车里，由全美模特萨曼莎·霍普斯拿着，在航空母舰上，在自由女神像的注视下，她欣赏着最美式的厚汉堡，配上切开的热狗——
It can be really hard to figure out what to say even about a burger that's delicious. And sometimes they get stuck, like when they put pulled pork on a burger-- not the most appetizing picture the way I just described it. And Brad says it didn't test well.
即使是关于一个美味的汉堡，想好说什么也很难。有时他们会卡住，就像他们把手撕猪肉放在汉堡上时——我刚才描述的样子一点也不开胃。布拉德说测试效果不好。
And we kept trying different names. We had called it the pulled pork burger or the southern burger. And finally, I think Bruce had the idea of calling it the Memphis Barbecue Burger. And we tried that and it worked incredibly well.
我们一直在尝试不同的名字。我们叫它手撕猪肉汉堡或南方汉堡。最后，我想布鲁斯有了叫它孟菲斯烧烤汉堡的念头。我们尝试了那个，效果好得惊人。
What do you think it is about the word "Memphis" that's evocative in the way that pulled pork is not?
你认为“孟菲斯”这个词有什么唤起力是“手撕猪肉”没有的？
I think it made it a bigger story. And Memphis obviously just sounds like they would know barbecue, so it sounded like it was more of a creation.
我认为这让它成为了一个更大的故事。显然孟菲斯听起来就像他们懂得烧烤，所以听起来这更像是一种创作。
The chicken masher needs that kind of story. Say the mama's chicken sandwich, like a Sunday chicken dinner at grandma's on a farm with a handmade quilt as the tablecloth with a basket of puppies on the table. And you're seven years old again and it's your birthday. And they're considering something like that, but they're cautious. Even the macaroni and cheese burger, they tell me, is an easier sell than the chicken masher.
鸡肉碎汉堡需要那种故事。比如妈妈的鸡肉三明治，就像奶奶农场里的周日鸡肉晚餐，手工被子当桌布，桌上放着一篮子小狗。你又回到了七岁，是你的生日。他们正在考虑类似的东西，但他们很谨慎。他们告诉我，即使是麦克奶酪汉堡，也比鸡肉碎汉堡更容易推销。
Cheese is something that people already are looking for on a burger, that they expect on a burger. We've only thrown one new thing in. Throwing in mashed potatoes and gravy is not something people have really ever seen on a chicken sandwich. So the macaroni is the new part of the macaroni and cheese. The mashed potatoes and gravy is all new.
奶酪是人们已经在汉堡中寻找的东西，他们期望在汉堡里有奶酪。我们只加了一样新东西。把土豆泥和肉汁加进去，是人们以前从未在鸡肉三明治上见过的东西。所以麦克奶酪只是麦克奶酪汉堡中“新”的部分。而土豆泥和肉汁则全是新的。
Oh, I see. The leap is greater, you think, for the person getting the sandwich.
噢，我明白了。你认为对于吃三明治的人来说，这种跨度更大。
The leap is greater.
跨度更大。
Mashed potatoes goes too far. Note: At this stage in this kitchen, there are no consumer surveys, no charts in front of them, no research, just gut. They just have a feeling people will be weirded out. And that feeling is built into this process.
土豆泥走得太远了。注：在这个阶段的厨房里，没有任何消费者调查，他们面前没有任何图表，没有任何研究，只有直觉。他们只是感觉人们会感到怪异。而这种感觉已经融入了这个过程。
What happens next is more data driven. They test some of the sandwiches in a dozen restaurants, put up all the advertising like it's a national rollout, then survey everyone who orders one. But that's in the future. For now, it's Brad, Bruce, Mark, and Eric just geeking out here in the room where it happens. It's like somebody playing you their favorite songs.
接下来发生的是更多基于数据驱动的事情。他们在十几家餐厅测试一些三明治，像全国推广一样打广告，然后调查每一个订购的人。但那是在未来。现在，布拉德、布鲁斯、马克和埃里克只是在这个发生一切的房间里玩着极客游戏。就像有人在为你播放他们最喜欢的歌曲。
Brad came up with this one. It tastes like-- well, see what you think, but it tastes like a pepperoni pizza with a French fry crust, which is kind of like two wonderful things coming together.
布拉德想出了这个。它尝起来——嗯，看看你怎么想，但它尝起来像披萨配薯条饼底，就像两件美妙的东西结合在一起。
The guys seem to like it. I don't. I'm like, why bathe fries in marinara? Why macaroni and cheese yes and mashed potatoes no? There is no answer. There's mystery. It's just a feeling.
伙计们似乎很喜欢。我不喜欢。我在想，为什么要把薯条泡在番茄酱里？为什么麦克奶酪可以，土豆泥不行？没有答案。这是一个谜。这只是一种感觉。
Zoe Chace is one of the producers of our show.
佐伊·蔡斯是我们节目的制作人之一。
[MUSIC - "THE ROOM WHERE IT HAPPENS" BY LESLIE ODOM, JR., LIN-MANUEL MIRANDA, DAVEED DIGGS, ORIERIETE ONAODOWAN, AND ORIGINAL BROADWAY CAST OF HAMILTON]
[音乐 - “发生这一切的房间”，由小莱斯利·奥多姆、林-曼努埃尔·米兰达、戴维德·迪格斯、奥里耶特·奥纳多万及汉密尔顿原版百老汇卡司演唱]
Act Two, the wedding crasher. So today's program is about situations where the facts are not enough by themselves. You need to still figure out what story best goes with those facts. So the ad about your new fast food burger is as important as the ingredients. Well, Ahamefule Oluo has been puzzling over how to tell one story for a lot of his life. It's the story of a stranger who also is his dad.
第二幕，婚礼捣乱者。所以今天的节目是关于事实本身不足以说明问题的情况。你仍然需要找出最符合这些事实的故事。所以关于你新快餐汉堡的广告和配料一样重要。好吧，阿哈梅福勒·奥卢奥一生中大部分时间都在困惑如何讲述一个故事。这是一个关于一个既是陌生人又是他父亲的故事。
I always say that I've never met my father, but that's not really true. I once spent an entire month with him. Unfortunately, it was the first month of my life, and I was too busy chewing on my own fist to make the most out of this quality time.
我总是说我从来没有见过我父亲，但这并不是真的。我曾经和他在一起整整一个月。不幸的是，那是由于我人生中的第一个月，我忙于咀嚼自己的拳头，没能充分利用这段高质量的时光。
My parents had been together seven years when my father went home to visit his family in Nigeria and didn't come back. He had come to the United States to go to college. As soon as he got here, he met my mom, a white lady from Wichita. They got married, had two kids. And then, two months after he graduated with his doctorate and one month after I was born, he was gone, continents away. And he never saw his wife and kids ever again.
我父母在一起七年了，当时我父亲回尼日利亚探望家人，结果没有回来。他是来美国上大学的。他一到这里，就遇到了我妈妈，一个来自威奇托的白人女士。他们结婚了，有了两个孩子。然后，在他获得博士学位两个月后，在我出生一个月后，他就离开了，远在大陆的另一端。他再也没有见过他的妻子和孩子。
Growing up, I knew a lot of other kids whose dads weren't around, but I had nothing in common with them. Their dads were deadbeats. Mine was a powerful African chief who was going to return any day to save us. I knew this because that's what my mom told me all the time. Of course, my mom didn't know he wasn't coming back. So to prepare for his return, she raised us to be Nigerian, or as Nigerian as a sheltered white woman from Kansas could.
成长过程中，我认识很多其他父亲不在身边的孩子，但我与他们毫无共同之处。他们的父亲是游手好闲的人。我的父亲是一位强大的非洲酋长，随时都会回来拯救我们。我知道这一点，因为那是我妈妈一直告诉我的。当然，我妈妈不知道他不会回来了。所以为了迎接他的回归，她把我们培养成尼日利亚人，或者说像一个来自堪萨斯的被保护得很好的白人女性所能做到的那样，培养成尼日利亚人。
Our comfort food was jollof rice, fufu, and egusi soup. When I got in trouble, my mom would yell, [NIGERIAN], which my older sister and I understood as Nigerian for "Watch out. Mom's pissed." And then mom would say, "Your father would never let you get away with that." She talked about him like he was still our dad, like he was a presence instead of an absence.
我们的舒心食物是杰洛夫米饭、富富和埃古西汤。当我惹麻烦时，我妈妈会大喊，[尼日利亚语]，我和姐姐明白那是尼日利亚语，意思是“小心。妈妈生气了。”然后妈妈会说，“你父亲绝不会让你那样做。”她谈论他就像他还像我们的父亲一样，就像他是一个存在而不是缺失。
My mom always refers to her years with my father as the best time of her life. They lived in a small African immigrant community in Texas. My mom dove head first into Nigerian life. She wore a traditional wrap and prepared feasts with the other women. My dad was in fact a chief, which is an honorary title. In practice, it meant my mom and dad were often invited to weddings as the guests of honor. And he'd pull out some crazy jewelry for the occasion and give a toast. He was always great at giving toasts. She told me my dad had a commanding presence that could make a room go silent.
我妈妈总是把她和我父亲在一起的日子称为她一生中最美好的时光。他们生活在德克萨斯州的一个小型非洲移民社区。我妈妈一头扎进了尼日利亚的生活。她穿着传统的裹裙，和其他女性一起准备盛宴。我父亲实际上是一位酋长，这是一个荣誉称号。在实践中，这意味着我父亲和母亲经常被邀请作为贵宾参加婚礼。他会为这个场合拿出一些疯狂的珠宝并致辞。他总是很擅长祝酒。她告诉我，我父亲有一种威严的存在感，能让房间安静下来。
The way she described it, it was paradise. Everyone took care of one another. If you didn't have any food, you could just go to your neighbor's apartment and they would feed you, no questions asked, which sounded great to me when I was a kid because we often didn't have food. My mom did everything she could-- manual labor, odd jobs. But it was just so much for her to bear on her own. At night, she would lock herself in her room and cry. My sister and I could hear it, but no one talked about it. When our electricity or our phone would get cut off, my mom would say something like, things will be different when your dad comes back, or we won't have to worry about this when we move to Nigeria.
按照她的描述，那是天堂。每个人都互相照顾。如果你没有食物，你可以直接去邻居家，他们会喂饱你，不问任何问题，这在我小时候听起来很棒，因为我们经常没有食物。我妈妈尽了她所能——体力劳动、打零工。但这对她一个人来说负担太重了。晚上，她会把自己锁在房间里哭。我和姐姐能听到，但没人谈论它。当我们断电或断电话时，我妈妈会说类似的话，比如你爸爸回来后一切都会好起来的，或者当我们搬到尼日利亚时，我们就不必担心这个了。
I wanted to be Nigerian like my dad. Anytime I would do a geography report in school, it was always on Nigeria. Until the second grade, everyone I knew, including my family, called me by my middle name, Joe. It was the only name I'd ever known. When I learned that my actual first name was Ahamefule, a Nigerian name, I immediately made an executive decision that I never wanted anyone to call me Joe ever again. My grandparents thought it was a phase. It wasn't.
我想像我父亲一样成为尼日利亚人。任何时候我在学校做地理报告，它总是关于尼日利亚的。直到二年级，我认识的每个人，包括我的家人，都叫我中间名，乔。这是我唯一知道的名字。当我了解到我的真实名字是阿哈梅福勒，一个尼日利亚名字时，我立即做出了一个行政决定，我不希望任何人再叫我乔。我的祖父母以为那只是个阶段。其实不然。
It went beyond the name. I wanted to look Nigerian. Unfortunately, I didn't really know what Nigerians looked like and Google Images didn't exist at the time. So my school photos are basically a 10-year-old's best guess-- a weird hat, a colorful print shirt, a shark tooth necklace. Why not? Nigeria's by the ocean, right?
这超越了名字。我想看起来像尼日利亚人。不幸的是，我真的不知道尼日利亚人长什么样，而且当时还没有谷歌图片。所以我的学校照片基本上是一个10岁孩子的最佳猜测——一顶奇怪的帽子，一件彩色印花衬衫，一条鲨鱼牙项链。为什么不呢？尼日利亚在海边，对吧？
Years passed. He never called. He never wrote a single letter. My mom started talking about my dad less and less until she didn't really talk about him at all anymore. Looking back on it now, I'm sure she gave up hope he'd ever return, and it got too embarrassing to pretend he would. There was no moment when we decided as a family to face the facts, and she never divorced him. She never said a negative word about him.
岁月流逝。他从没打过电话。他从没写过一封信。我妈妈开始越来越少地谈论我父亲，直到她真的不再谈论他了。现在回想起来，我肯定她已经放弃了他会回来的希望，假装他会回来变得太尴尬了。我们没有决定作为一个家庭面对事实的时刻，她也从未和他离婚。她从未说过关于他的一句负面话。
In my teenage years, I put away the African hat. It felt like I'd been wearing a birthday hat to a party that no one else showed up to. Up to this point, I had wholeheartedly embraced my mother's story about my dad. But now I started considering alternatives.
在我十几岁的时候，我收起了那顶非洲帽子。感觉就像我戴着生日帽去参加一个没有人来的派对。到目前为止，我已经全身心地接受了我妈妈关于我父亲的故事。但现在我开始考虑其他选择。
My mom's parents never liked my dad. They were convinced that this was purely a green card marriage, an elaborate plot to take advantage of their young and innocent daughter. My sister, who's just a year older than me, never bought my mom's story about my dad either. She acted like he didn't exist. I tried to do the same.
我妈妈的父母从不喜欢我父亲。他们坚信这纯粹是一场绿卡婚姻，是一个利用他们年轻天真的女儿的精心策划的阴谋。我姐姐，只比我大一岁，也从不相信我妈妈关于我父亲的故事。她的表现就像他不存在一样。我也试着这样做。
And then, when I was 16, my dad sent us a letter. The letter was addressed to my sister Ijeoma and me from the Honorable Chief Dr. Samuel Oluo. In it, he expressed how excited he was to finally find us. We weren't hiding. And he included his telephone number in Port Harcourt, Nigeria.
然后，当我16岁时，我父亲给我们写了一封信。信是写给我姐姐伊杰奥马和我的，署名是尊敬的首席博士塞缪尔·奥卢奥。信中，他表达了终于找到我们的兴奋之情。我们没有躲藏。他还附上了他在尼日利亚哈科特港的电话号码。
Our father talked to Ijeoma first. She told him how excited she was to start college in the fall. She was going to study political science, just like he did. She told him about her job at the bookstore. They talked for about 20 minutes, and then it was my turn.
我们的父亲先和伊杰奥马谈了话。她告诉他秋天要上大学有多兴奋。她要学习政治学，就像他一样。她告诉他她在书店的工作。他们谈了大约20分钟，然后轮到我了。
My hands shook as I clutched the large, black, cordless telephone. Hello, I said. "Ahamefule," he shouted, loud and distorted by the terrible connection. "It is so great to hear your voice. I have missed you so very much. Tell me about yourself. What do you want to be when you grow up?"
当我紧紧抓住那个巨大的黑色无绳电话时，我的手在颤抖。你好，我说。“阿哈梅福勒，”他大喊，声音因糟糕的连线而扭曲。“能听到你的声音真是太好了。我非常想念你们。告诉我关于你自己的事情。你长大后想成为什么样的人？”
Well, I replied, I'm already doing what I want to do when I grow up. I'm a musician. I play the trumpet. I'm already starting to get paid and everything. The line went silent. "No, no. That is not good. I do not approve. You need to do something more sensible. Musician is not a job. You can't support a family with musician."
嗯，我回答说，我已经在做我长大后想做的事了。我是一名音乐家。我吹小号。我已经开始赚钱了，什么都有。电话那头沉默了。“不，不。那不好。我不赞成。你需要做更明智的事情。音乐家不是一份工作。你养不活家庭的。”
My eyes welled with tears. "Can you put Ijeoma back on the phone," he said, sounding resigned. I handed her the telephone, walked into the kitchen, and poured myself a glass of water.
我的眼睛里涌出了泪水。“你能让伊杰奥马接电话吗，”他说，听起来很无奈。我把电话递给她，走进厨房，给自己倒了一杯水。
I was done. What kind of person did this to their family? A bad person, that's what kind. I hated him. He tried to call a couple more times, but I didn't answer. And then he stopped calling.
我受够了。什么样的人会对他们的家人做这种事？坏人，就是那种。我恨他。他又尝试打了几次电话，但我没接。然后他就不再打了。
After this, I started to look at my mom with pity. How did she get duped that bad? It's so humiliating. And how could she drag me into her delusions like that? I wasn't going to let myself be like her anymore. I got closer to my sister. A year later, I moved out of the house. I was 17. I moved on with my life.
此后，我开始用怜悯的眼光看我妈妈。她怎么会被骗得那么惨？真丢人。而且她怎么能把我也拖进她的幻想中？我再也不想让自己像她那样了。我和姐姐更亲近了。一年后，我搬出了那个家。我17岁了。我继续我的生活。
Eight years passed. On Tuesday February 21, 2006, I received a phone call from a Nigerian half brother I'd never met informing me that our father had died. We only spoke on the phone for a few moments. The connection was terrible. I remember that I was wearing a yellow shirt, which seemed like a ridiculous color for the occasion.
八年过去了。2006年2月21日星期二，我接到了一个从未见过的尼日利亚同父异母兄弟的电话，通知我父亲去世了。我们在电话里只聊了一会儿。连线很糟糕。我记得我穿了一件黄色的衬衫，这在当时看起来是一个荒谬的颜色。
I felt so stupid for crying that it made me cry more. The only solace I had is that I knew that this was going to be the last time. It was over. The nail was literally in the coffin, or whatever people in Nigeria are buried in. And just like that, I turned the corner from I've never met my father to I will never meet my father. The story was final. It had a beginning, a middle, and now an end. He was a father who had abandoned his children forever.
我觉得为哭泣感到愚蠢，这让我哭得更厉害。我唯一的慰藉是，我知道这将是最后一次。结束了。棺材板真的盖上了，或者尼日利亚人埋葬在什么东西里。就这样，我从“我从未见过父亲”转变到了“我永远不会见到父亲”。这个故事定局了。它有一个开头，一个中间，现在是一个结尾。他是一个永远抛弃了孩子的父亲。
I got married this past July. It was a small ceremony at a cabin outside of Seattle. We worked hard to cull the guest list down to a manageable number. On the day, there was only one person who showed up uninvited. He was someone I had never met, my Nigerian half-brother Basil, the one who had called me nine years earlier to tell me about our father's death. I had no idea he even knew I was getting married, yet there he was in the woods in America, insisting from the moment he arrived that he needed to give a toast. Because it's a wedding, we have it on video.
今年7月我结婚了。这是一个小型的仪式，在西雅图外的一个小木屋里。我们努力把客单缩减到一个可控的数量。那天，只有一个人是不请自来的。他是我从未见过的人，我的尼日利亚同父异母兄弟巴兹尔，就是九年前打电话告诉我父亲去世的那个人。我根本不知道他甚至知道我要结婚，但他就在美国的森林里，从他到达的那一刻起就坚持要致祝酒词。因为这是婚礼，我们有录像。
I'm glad that I'm here to see this day. I'm glad that Aham and Ijeoma have grown to be so beautiful and so intelligent.
我很高兴我在这里见证这一天。我很高兴阿哈姆和伊杰奥马成长得如此美丽和聪明。
It was like he was speaking to us on behalf of our father.
感觉就像他代表我们父亲在和我们说话。
I assure you that the family back home in Africa is so proud of you. And they left me a message, which is to tell you that whatever it is you've lost, whatever emotional damages you've suffered, we're going to make sure you get all of it back.
我向你们保证，在非洲的家人为你们感到骄傲。他们给我留下了一个口信，就是告诉你们，无论你们失去了什么，无论你们遭受了什么样的情感伤害，我们一定会确保你们全部找回来。
I had no idea where this was going. And then, Basil said he wanted to clear something up about my parents' marriage.
我不知道这要往哪里去。然后，巴兹尔说他想澄清关于我父母婚姻的一件事。
Everyone would know that that marriage was real. It was never a green card marriage and it would never be a green card marriage because he has a green card.
每个人都知道那场婚姻是真实的。那从来不是绿卡婚姻，也永远不会是绿卡婚姻，因为他有绿卡。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
I can't explain how bizarre this felt to hear my long lost Nigerian brother talking at my wedding about my mother's marriage to our dead father. Nobody quite knew how to react. Mostly, people laughed. My mom was standing to my left. She was bawling. He was saying her marriage was real. It was what she had said all along.
我无法解释听到我失散多年的尼日利亚兄弟在我的婚礼上谈论我母亲与我已故父亲的婚姻是多么奇怪。没有人知道该如何反应。大多数人笑了。我妈妈站在我左边。她在嚎啕大哭。他说她的婚姻是真实的。这正是她一直所说的。
Basil was staying for five weeks, and he was staying at my house, both facts I was unaware of until he got here. He came with giant bags of gifts from Nigeria-- native instruments, handmade clothing, jewelry, and even antiques from our family's village. He was on a heartfelt mission. His mom had been begging him for years to put the family back together.
巴兹尔要待五周，而且他住在我家，这两个事实在我不知道的情况下他就已经到了。他带来了大包小包的尼日利亚礼物——民族乐器、手工服装、珠宝，甚至我们家族村庄的古董。他带着一个衷心的使命。他妈妈多年来一直求他把这个家庭重新聚在一起。
And more than anything, he wanted us to get to know each other. He told me that he wanted to go everywhere that I went. He came with me when I ran errands. He even came to my business meetings. I make my living as a musician, and while he was here, I was playing trumpet in a play. Basil went to the play three nights in a row. He said he loved it. He said my dad would have loved it, too.
而且最重要的是，他希望我们互相了解。他告诉我他想去我去过的每一个地方。我跑腿时他跟着我。他甚至参加了我的商务会议。我以音乐家为生，他在这儿的时候，我在一个剧里吹小号。巴兹尔连续三个晚上都去看那部剧。他说他很喜欢。他说我爸爸也会很喜欢的。
We talked for hours every day, a lot about our dad. As far as I knew, Ijeoma and I had been basically forgotten decades ago, tossed aside and never spoken about again. But Basil still says that wasn't true. According to Basil, my father had baby pictures of me and Ijeoma hanging in his house, and not just baby pictures. Later, he had photos of me as an adult with my two daughters that he printed from MySpace. I didn't even know that he knew he had grandkids in America.
我们每天谈论几个小时，很多是关于我们的爸爸。据我所知，伊杰奥马和我几十年前基本上已经被遗忘了，被抛在一边，再也没被提起过。但巴兹尔一直说那不是真的。据巴兹尔说，我父亲家里挂着我和伊杰奥马的婴儿照片，不仅是婴儿照片。后来，他还有我成年后与我的两个女儿的照片，那是他从MySpace打印出来的。我甚至不知道他知道他在美国有孙女。
He told everyone in Nigeria about us. He told them my mom was an amazing woman and he couldn't wait for everyone to meet her. He even had property set aside to build a house for us. There was a whole plan. He would get elected to political office, start making money, and then send for us.
他告诉尼日利亚的每一个人关于我们的事。他告诉他们我妈妈是一个了不起的女性，他迫不及待地想让大家见见她。他甚至预留了房产为我们建房子。有一个完整的计划。他会被选为公职人员，开始赚钱，然后把我们接过去。
And at first, his plan was working. My father was elected to state office right after he got back to Nigeria, but then was deposed in a military coup after only months. Basil said he had bad luck his entire career. He was always struggling financially. Basil was saying our dad really wanted to bring us to Nigeria. I asked him if I could record us talking about this just-- I don't know-- to get it on the record. When we sat down, he told me that people in Nigeria knew our dad abandoned us, and it was the source of his biggest shame. He always planned to fix it.
起初，他的计划奏效了。我父亲回到尼日利亚后立即被选为州公职人员，但仅仅几个月后就在军事政变中被免职。巴兹尔说他职业生涯一直运气不好。他总是经济拮据。巴兹尔说我们的爸爸真的很想把我们带到尼日利亚。我问他能不能把我们谈论这件事的过程录下来，好让它留下记录。当我们坐下来时，他告诉我，尼日利亚的人们都知道我们的爸爸抛弃了我们，这是他最大的耻辱来源。他一直计划修复它。
I think he kept thinking that there will be a time when everything would be fine, and then everyone will be together again. Unfortunately, it's not working.
我想他一直认为会有一个时间一切都会好起来，然后大家会再次团聚。不幸的是，这没有成功。
Basil is only 11 months younger than me. And if you remember that I was one month old when my father left, you already know the first thing he did when he got back to Nigeria. Basil told me that my dad had 12 kids, a few of them older than me and my sister, which means he deserted their family to start ours. My father didn't have a great relationship with most of his children, but Basil said it was different. The culture is different. Polygamy is normal, and children don't have the same expectations of their fathers.
巴兹尔只比我小11个月。如果你记得我父亲离开时我一个月大，你就已经知道他回到尼日利亚后做的第一件事了。巴兹尔告诉我，我爸爸有12个孩子，其中几个比我和姐姐还大，这意味着他抛弃了他们的家庭来建立我们的。我父亲与他的大多数孩子关系都不好，但巴兹尔说情况不同。文化不同。一夫多妻制是正常的，孩子们对父亲没有同样的期望。
You don't blame him so much. The African society doesn't actually demand as much fatherhood as the Western culture does demand. You could have kids and be caring in the African sense, but in the Western sense be absolutely nowhere.
你并没有太责怪他。非洲社会实际上并不要求像西方文化那样多的父爱。你可以在非洲意义上拥有孩子并照顾他们，但在西方意义上却完全不存在。
Still, Basil was deeply hurt that our father wasn't around for him. He refused to call him dad. He calls him Sam. But like me, Basil was obsessed with him growing up. Even though he wasn't a great dad, Basil says he was a really great guy. My dad went back to his village to visit his mom every single weekend, even in terrible weather. Apparently, he helped a lot of young people get into college. He cared about his community. He was genuinely dedicated, an incorruptible politician in the most corrupt country on earth.
尽管如此，巴兹尔还是因为我们的父亲不在他身边而深受伤害。他拒绝叫他爸爸。他叫他山姆。但像我一样，巴兹尔成长过程中对他着迷。尽管他不是一个伟大的父亲，巴兹尔说他是一个真正伟大的人。我爸爸每个周末都回村里看望他的妈妈，即使天气恶劣。显然，他帮助很多年轻人进入了大学。他关心他的社区。他是一个真正奉献的人，是地球上最腐败的国家里一个不可腐蚀的政客。
It was really difficult for me listening to my brother talk about all the great things our father did for other people. Why couldn't he have been dedicated to us? I swung back and forth between sympathy and anger. I couldn't stop thinking about him. When I woke up, when I went to bed, when I was on stage playing the trumpet, he was still on my mind.
听着我兄弟谈论我父亲为别人做的所有伟大的事情对我来说真的很困难。为什么他不能对我们奉献呢？我不断在同情和愤怒之间摇摆。我无法停止想他。当我醒来时，当我上床睡觉时，当我在舞台上吹小号时，他还在我的脑海里。
Were my mom and Basil right? Was he this fantastic guy? Or was he a deadbeat who didn't really care about his own kids? I decided to get everyone together-- my brother, my mom, and my sister Ijeoma. We met at my mom's one bedroom apartment. She made Nigerian shrimp and rice, and then we sat down in a circle in the living room.
我妈妈和巴兹尔是对的吗？他真是个了不起的人吗？还是一个并不真正关心自己孩子的游手好闲的人？我决定把所有人都聚在一起——我的兄弟、我妈妈和我姐姐伊杰奥马。我们在我妈妈的一居室公寓里见面。她做了尼日利亚虾仁饭，然后我们在客厅里围成一圈坐下。
So anyway.
总之。
Thank you, everyone, for coming here.
谢谢大家今天能来。
Yes.
是的。
My mom said you couldn't imagine what this meant to her. She and Basil had been talking, and she was so happy to hear that she was right all those years, that our dad had missed us.
我妈妈说你无法想象这对比她意味着什么。她和巴兹尔一直在谈话，她很高兴听到她这些年来是对的，我们的爸爸确实想念我们。
Well, I made up my own little story. And my own story was actually probably pretty close to actually what it was. And that was that he had so many responsibilities back home. And that was my belief. And that he knew I'd be fine with my family here and that his family back home wouldn't be. And that's what I had in my head.
好吧，我编造了我自己的小故事。而我自己的故事实际上可能非常接近实际情况。那就是他在老家有很多责任。这就是我的信念。而且他知道我在家里和家人在一起会很好，而他在老家的家人不会。这就是我脑子里的想法。
But in a lot of ways, we weren't fine, though.
但在很多方面，我们并不好。
No, I know.
不，我知道。
But I mean, in terms of--
但是我的意思是，在——
But, I mean, that's what he thought I thought. You know, I thought he thought that.
但是，我的意思是，那就是他以为我想的那样。你知道，我以为他那么想。
You thought that he thought that you were--
你以为他以为你——
Yeah. Yeah. And back then, my mom and dad were making really good money. And I thought maybe he thought that they would take care of us and not know that we were desperately poor five different ways.
是啊。是啊。在那个时候，我父母确实赚了很多钱。我想也许他认为他们会照顾好我们，不知道我们其实在五个不同的方面绝望地贫穷。
I remember when we were so poor, I remember thinking, I wonder if my dad knows how poor we are?
记得当我们很穷的时候，我记得我在想，我想知道我爸爸是否知道我们有多穷？
Yeah. I've thought that, too.
是啊。我也这样想过。
And if that would make any difference.
如果那会有什么不同的话。
Well, who knows, because everyone back home, too, believes that you guys are doing fine.
好吧，谁知道呢，因为老家的每个人也相信你们过得很好。
Yeah.
是啊。
He says everyone back home believes you're doing fine. Basil says that if our dad had known, that would have made a difference, just as my mom always believed it would. He would have figured out a way to help. And if he was alive today, he would have wanted to come to my wedding to visit us.
他说老家的每个人都认为你们过得很好。巴兹尔说，如果我们的爸爸知道，那会有所不同，正如我妈妈一直相信的那样。他会想出一个办法来帮忙。如果他今天还活着，他会想来参加我的婚礼来看我们。
He would have wanted to come.
他会想来的。
Well, I'm glad that you came instead of him.
好吧，我很高兴是你来了，而不是他。
That's my sister Ijeoma. She says our dad visiting may have helped me and my mom, but not her.
那是我的姐姐伊杰奥马。她说我们的父亲访问可能对我和我妈妈有帮助，但对她没有。
But you being here means a lot. You aren't our dad and you weren't his mistakes. You aren't any of that. You're just our brother, so I'm glad that you came.
但你能来意义重大。你不是我们的爸爸，你也不是他的错误。你根本不是那些。你只是我们的兄弟，所以我很高兴你来了。
Sam would have made you think otherwise.
山姆会让你想别的。
Basil says Sam, our dad, would have made you think otherwise.
巴兹尔说山姆，我们的爸爸，会让你想别的。
You know, I've talked to him.
你知道，我和他谈过。
He's not about-- I know that man, you know. He's very forceful.
他不关于——我了解那个人，你知道。他非常有主见。
He's very forceful. Basically, he would have won you over. My mom is nodding enthusiastically.
他非常有主见。基本上，他会赢得你的好感。我妈妈在热情地点头。
Yeah.
是啊。
He knows how to get at things.
他知道如何处理事情。
Don't you see him in her?
你不觉得在他身上看到他吗？
That's-- you know, you just say all of this--
那——你知道，你只是说所有这些——
She doesn't know it.
她不知道。
You just say all of this because he's not here. If he had come, no. My goodness.
你只是说所有这些因为他不在这儿。如果他来了，不。我的天哪。
I think the thing, though, Basil, I don't think you understand what it's like watching the people you love most in the world go through so much pain because of someone who's not here. And that was my only wound. I never felt like I wish I had a dad, never. I don't think I ever thought that to myself. I never thought, I wish I had a dad. What I remember thinking was, I wish my mom wasn't so heartbroken all the time and crying all the time, and I wish that she was happy and I wish she saw how--
但我认为，巴兹尔，我不认为你明白看着你在这个世界上最爱的人因为一个不在这里的人经历这么多痛苦是什么感觉。那是我的唯一伤口。我从来没有觉得我希望有个爸爸，从来没有。我不认为我曾经对自己想过。我从来没有想过，我希望有个爸爸。我记得我当时在想，我希望我妈妈不是一直那么心碎和哭泣，我希望她快乐，我希望她看到——
Yeah, but that's because you didn't know him.
是啊，但那是因为你不了解他。
No, but mom, no--
不，但妈妈，不——
Wait, wait, wait. Let me just say what I want to say, and that is put yourself back in the '70s in Denton, Texas.
等等，等等，等等。让我只说我想说的，那就是把自己放回70年代德克萨斯州的丹顿。
This is a story my mom loves to tell about my dad, how he won over everyone in their small white town with his charm, how he got them all to celebrate Nigerian Independence Day.
这是我妈妈喜欢讲的一个关于我爸爸的故事，他如何用魅力赢得了他们小镇上的每个人，他如何让他们所有人庆祝尼日利亚独立日。
Everybody was just, you know, amazed at what he created. He had that whole entire town.
每个人都只是，你知道，惊叹于他所创造的一切。他拥有了整个小镇。
I don't know what that has to do with what I was talking about.
我不知道这和我刚才谈论的有什么关系。
He was an amazing man.
他是个了不起的人。
He was an amazing man who left his kids and sent two letters in 30 years.
他是一个了不起的人，但他抛弃了他的孩子，30年里只写了两封信。
I know. I know.
我知道。我知道。
So for me--
所以对我来说——
I know, but see, that's what I have.
我知道，但是看，这就是我所拥有的。
But what-- I know. And that's your truth.
但是什么——我知道。而那是你的真相。
But, I mean, that's why I grieved. That's why--
但是，我的意思是，这就是我悲伤的原因。这就是——
Yeah, I know. But I feel like this is-- maybe this is why I'm not good at these sorts of conversations in groups because I feel like everybody tries to make their personal reality everyone else's reality. And for me--
是啊，我知道。但我感觉这是——也许这就是我不擅长在团体中进行这类谈话的原因，因为我觉得每个人都试图把他们的个人现实变成其他人的现实。对我来说——
No, I don't.
不，我没有。
--it doesn't mean anything to me what type of person he is because he had no part in raising me, no part at all of anything. He was a detriment to my upbringing. And I don't want anyone to push him on me.
——他是什么样的人对我来说毫无意义，因为他在抚养我方面没有参与，任何事情都没有参与。他是我的成长的一个损害因素。我不希望任何人把关于他的东西推给我。
Yeah, no.
是啊，不。
I don't want to think anything about him because he chose not to be here. You're my brother because you're here and you're being my brother. You're my brother.
我不想关于他想任何事，因为他选择不在这里。你是我的兄弟是因为你在这里，你在做我的兄弟。你是我的兄弟。
It's hard to argue with that. I feel the same. What use is an amazing man that didn't want you? Basil listens carefully to Ijeoma.
很难反驳这一点。我有同样的感觉。一个不想要你的了不起的人有什么用？巴兹尔仔细听着伊杰奥马的话。
Everyone, you know, has the right to feel--
每个人，你知道，都有权利感觉——
They do.
他们有的。
--as they feel right now. But I tell you, if Sam was here today, you probably would have been mad at him for one week, two weeks, or three weeks. He would have found his way into your heart. That's the truth.
——像他们现在感觉的那样。但我告诉你，如果山姆今天在这里，你可能会生他的气一周、两周或三周。他会找到走进你心里的路。那是事实。
That's his truth, and my mom's too, but not Ijeoma's. And I'm as confused as ever. The only thing that's very clear to me now is I'm not going to get my answers from them.
那是他的真相，也是我妈妈的真相，但不是伊杰奥马的。而我依然困惑。现在对我来说唯一非常清楚的一点是，我不会从他们那里得到我的答案。
A few days after the conversation, I was driving out to a portrait studio in the suburbs. My mom had been saving a coupon for half off a family portrait, and she wanted to use it to get a picture with all of us wearing the traditional clothing Basil brought from Nigeria. Everyone was there-- my mom, my siblings, Ijeoma's two sons, my two daughters. It was the day before Basil's plane back to Nigeria.
谈话后几天，我开车去郊区的一家摄影工作室。我妈妈一直在存一张半价家庭肖像的优惠券，她想用它拍一张我们穿着巴兹尔从尼日利亚带来的传统服装的照片。每个人都在那里——我妈妈、我的兄弟姐妹、伊杰奥马的两个儿子、我的两个女儿。那是巴兹尔飞回尼日利亚的前一天。
The whole family took turns changing in the bathroom, safety pinning what wouldn't fit. My daughters and my nephews were playing around in the bright, colorful clothes of their ancestors, running and laughing, hitting each other on the head with ceremonial fly whisks. I was sitting in the corner, watching it all, still thinking about my dad. Hearing so much about him from Basil, what he was like as a real person, the ups and downs of his life, all the weekends he went back to his village, every young person he helped out. He had so long to fix things with us but he didn't. Every day was a new opportunity and he passed them all by until there were none left.
全家人轮流在浴室里换衣服，用别针别住那些不合身的衣服。我的女儿和侄子们穿着他们祖先明亮多彩的衣服在玩耍，跑来跑去，笑着，用仪式的苍蝇掸子互相打头。我坐在角落里，看着这一切，还在想我的爸爸。从巴兹尔那里听到这么多关于他的事情，他作为一个人是什么样子的，他生活的起伏，他每个周末回村里，他帮助过的每一个年轻人。他有那么长时间去修复与我们的关系，但他没有。每一天都是一个新的机会，他都错过了，直到不再有任何机会。
I looked around me at my family, and I felt something I had never felt before. I felt pity for him. He never learned to be a father. He never got what I have now. I can't imagine never seeing my kids again. It would ruin my life. All he had were photos printed from the internet. I get the photos and the real family.
我环顾四周我的家人，我感觉到一种我以前从未有过的感觉。我为他感到怜悯。他从未学会如何成为一个父亲。他从未得到我现在拥有的。我无法想象再也见不到我的孩子。那会毁了我的生活。他所拥有的只是从互联网上打印出来的照片。我得到了照片和真实的家庭。
[MUSIC - "FILL THE VOID" BY THE NOTHING AND THE GOLDENHORN]
[音乐 - “填补空白”，由Nothing和Goldenhorn演唱]
Ahamefule Oluo is a musician and writer in Seattle. He's written a musical about his dad called Now I'm Fine. It's going to be at Under the Radar Festival at the Public Theater in New York this coming January.
阿哈梅福勒·奥卢奥是西雅图的音乐家和作家。他写了一部关于他爸爸的音乐剧，叫《我现在很好》。明年1月将在纽约公共剧院的“Under the Radar”节上演出。
Coming up, what should Volkswagen's new slogan be? OK, I have a suggestion. My suggestion, "never again." And every ad executive we ran that idea by before this week's show hated that idea. What they suggested instead in a minute from Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
接下来，大众汽车的新标语应该是什么？好的，我有一个建议。我的建议是，“绝不再犯”。在我们本周节目播出前，每一个我们推销这个想法的广告主管都讨厌这个主意。在芝加哥公共广播节目的下一部分中，当我们的节目继续时，他们建议了什么。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose a theme, bring you different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's program, "Put a Bow on It." Each of our acts today is about a group of people who are trying to figure out not just the facts of a situation, but what story to tell-- to tell themselves, to tell others-- about it.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周在我们的节目中，当然，我们选择一个主题，带给你关于这个主题的不同种类的故事。今天的节目，“给它系上蝴蝶结”。我们今天的每一个环节都是关于一群试图理清事实，不仅是情况的事实，还有讲述什么故事——讲述给自己，讲述给他人——的人。
We've arrived at Act Three of our show. Act three, drivers wanted-- really, really wanted. So this thing occurred to all of us here when we were putting together today's radio show. You remember back in Act One, Zoe Chace talked to that guy Brad Haley, who was in charge of marketing in an old job for Jack in the Box back when four children died from E. coli. People stopped going to Jack in the Box and they had to create an ad campaign to turn things around, get the public's trust back.
我们已经进入了节目的第三幕。第三幕，寻找司机——真的，非常需要。所以当我们准备今天广播节目时，我们所有人都想到了这一点。你记得在第一幕中，佐伊·蔡斯采访了那个叫布拉德·黑利的家伙，他在一份旧工作中负责杰克在盒子的营销，当时四个孩子死于大肠杆菌。人们停止去杰克在盒子，他们必须制定一个广告宣传活动来扭转局面，赢得公众的信任。
Well, here around our office for weeks now, Zoe has been obsessed with another company, Volkswagen, that of course has been in the middle of a giant PR crisis ever since the revelation that they had been lying to consumers and cheating emission standards for years. And Zoe and all of us here when we heard about the Jack in the Box campaign when she was researching that story, we wondered, what kind of ad could VW do? What could VW possibly say right now to make us trust them again?
嗯，在我们办公室这几周，佐伊一直对另一家公司大众汽车着迷，自揭露他们多年来一直欺骗消费者和排放标准以来，他们一直处于巨大的公关危机中。当佐伊研究那个故事并听说杰克在盒子活动的广告时，我们所有人都想知道，大众能做什么样的广告？大众现在可能说些什么来让我们再次信任他们？
And so Zoe called that guy, Brad Haley, whose marketing brought back Jack in the Box from the edge to see what kind of advice he would give to VW. And she called his peers, other advertising people at other agencies, to find out what kind of ads they would make if VW were their client. Several of them actually went to the trouble to make ads for us, which Zoe has for you now. Full disclosure before we start, Volkswagen was once an underwriter, a sponsor, here on our program years ago. Anyway, here's Zoe again.
所以佐伊打电话给那个家伙，布拉德·黑利，他的营销把杰克在盒子从边缘带了回来，看看他会给大众什么建议。她还打电话给他的同行，其他代理机构的广告人，看看如果大众是他们的客户，他们会制作什么样的广告。其中几个人甚至特意为我们制作了广告，佐伊现在有给你的内容。在开始之前全披露，大众汽车曾是我们节目几年前的承销商和赞助商。总之，这里再次是佐伊。
The first thing Brad Haley told me when I got him on the phone is that ads can only do so much. He says to change how people feel about your company, to change your image, that takes time. They didn't have that luxury back then.
我打通电话时布拉德·黑利告诉我的第一件事是广告能做的有限。他说要改变人们对你们公司的感觉，改变你们的形象，这需要时间。他们当时没有那样的奢侈。
In our experience at Jack in the Box, I think we didn't have a lot of time because sales had been so horrifically damaged that I think the brand's survival was at stake.
在杰克在盒子的经验中，我认为我们没有太多时间，因为销售额受到了如此惨重的破坏，我认为品牌的生存危在旦夕。
So at first, they just cut prices to get people to come into their stores, no matter how afraid people were of being poisoned.
所以起初，他们只是降低价格，让人们走进他们的商店，无论人们多么害怕中毒。
We ran actually very aggressive deals to get people to come back. There was a deal called the Big Deal, I think it was. I remember it was a small hamburger, taco, fry, and a drink for $0.99. People still tell me that they remember getting that deal when they were in college when they were poor students. And that seemed to do a lot of the work. That got a lot of people back in the restaurant.
我们实际上进行了非常激进的交易，让人们回来。有一个叫“大交易”的，我想是这样。我记得那是一个小汉堡、塔可、薯条和饮料，只要0.99美元。人们仍然告诉我，他们记得在大学当贫穷学生时得到那个交易。这似乎起了很大作用。那让很多人回到了餐厅。
And then to change people's feelings about Jack in the Box, they did create an ad campaign, a famously successful one. The guy who came up with the idea for the ads and wrote them is Rick Sittig. He owns the ad agency Secret Weapon Marketing. He also came up with the Energizer bunny. So here's how he diagnoses the situation for Volkswagen right now.
然后为了改变人们对杰克在盒子的感觉，他们确实创造了一个广告宣传活动，一个极其成功的活动。想出广告点子并撰写的人是里克·斯蒂格。他拥有Secret Weapon Marketing广告公司。他还想出了Energizer兔子。这就是他现在为大众诊断情况的方式。
They're screwed because they have abused their customers' trust. And it takes a brand decades to win people over. There's no empathy out there for them.
他们搞砸了，因为他们滥用了客户的信任。一个品牌需要几十年的时间才能赢得人心。外面没有人对他们有同情心。
Back when Jack in the Box was in a similar situation, here's what Rick did. He says he knew people were looking for accountability.
当杰克在盒子处于类似情况时，里克是这样做的。他说他知道人们在寻找问责。
They want someone to pay for the mistake, and some head needs to roll. And it can either be real or it can be symbolic.
他们希望有人为错误买单，必须有人承担后果。这可以是真实的，也可以是象征性的。
So in the first spot in this ad campaign, a big headed clown in a business suit walks into the headquarters of Jack in the Box. He says he's the original founder of the company who had been forced out a long time ago.
所以在这个广告宣传活动的第一支短片中，一个穿着西装的大头小丑走进了杰克在盒子的总部。他说他是很久以前被赶走的公司创始人。
Hello. I'm Jack, founder of Jack in the Box. Perhaps you remember when I was fired.
你好。我是杰克，杰克在盒子的创始人。也许你记得我被解雇的时候。
Yes, Rick is the voice of Jack.
是的，里克是杰克的声音。
Today, I'm back, and ready to make Jack in the Box better than ever.
今天，我回来了，准备让杰克在盒子变得比以往更好。
Then, Jack explodes the boardroom, a room full of the old Jack in the Box management. Never does the clown say, sorry for all the E. coli that happened. He just says he's in control now and moves on-- not that this really happened in the real world. Jack in the Box did not fire their entire management team. They did make some big changes, like they totally revamped their food safety system.
然后，杰克炸毁了董事会会议室，房间里挤满了杰克在盒子旧管理层。小丑从没说，为所有发生的细菌事件感到抱歉。他只是说他现在掌权了，然后继续前进——并不是说这在现实世界中真的发生了。杰克在盒子并没有解雇他们整个管理团队。他们确实做了一些重大改变，比如他们彻底改革了食品安全系统。
So that was happening in the real world. And then symbolically, in the advertising world, they were under new management. And the new guy with the big head came in. And he was funny and charming. And everybody sort of forgot about the tragedy, and we were all moving on.
所以那在现实世界中正在发生。然后在广告世界中，象征性地，他们处于新的管理之下。新来的大头家伙进来了。他既有趣又迷人。大家多少忘记了那场悲剧，我们都在前进。
[KNOCKING]
[敲门声]
Did I win something?
我赢了什么吗？
My sources tell me you've been calling Jack in the Box "Junk in the Box."
我的消息来源告诉我，你一直叫杰克在盒子“垃圾在盒子”。
So?
那又怎样？
I take these things personally, Brad.
我个人很看重这些事情，布拉德。
Get lost.
滚开。
Sure. Just try my food, apologize, and I'll go.
当然。试着尝尝我的食物，道个歉，我就走。
I said beat it, clown.
我说了滚，小丑。
Listen, punk. I've spent millions of dollars improving my kitchens to make our best burgers ever.
听着，混蛋。我花了数百万美元改善我的厨房，制造我们有史以来最好的汉堡。
You're psycho!
你是个精神病！
Note that the customer apologizes to the company, not the other way around. That is how diabolical these ads are. And it worked. The number of Jack in the Box restaurants almost doubled in the years that this campaign was running.
请注意是客户向公司道歉，而不是反过来。这些广告就是这么邪恶。而且成功了。在这个活动期间，杰克在盒子餐厅的数量几乎翻了一番。
So Volkswagen, is there an advertising campaign that could maybe help them out?
那么大众汽车，有没有什么广告宣传活动可能帮助他们？
I only have one idea, and it's always blowing up people in a boardroom.
我只有一个想法，而且总是炸毁董事会里的人。
Rick actually doesn't want to give a new campaign to Volkswagen because Honda car dealers are a client of his, so they're a competitor. But three other ad agencies were up for making the next ad for Volkswagen. And calling around, I learned that for ad agencies, this is personal in a way I had no idea about. The reason they care so much is this magazine ad from 1959.
里克实际上不想给大众汽车新的宣传活动，因为本田汽车经销商是他的客户，所以他们是竞争对手。但其他三家广告公司也准备为大众制作下一个广告。在打电话过程中，我了解到对于广告公司来说，这是个人层面的，以我完全没有想到的方式。他们如此关心的原因是1959年的这本杂志广告。
Here comes this little kind of ugly car, and when a culture is screaming think big, everything was about bigger and more. And it takes this ad, puts the car really small in the corner surrounded by an immense amount of white space, and just says Think Small.
这辆有点丑的小车来了，当文化在高喊“想大”时，一切都是关于更大和更多。它拿这个广告，把车放得非常小，在角落里，被大量的留白包围，只是说“想小”。
Kirk Souder is co-founder of creative agency Enso. He studied this ad in school and the lemon ad that came after. Everybody does. Kirk's agency specializes in doing campaigns that make companies look like they care about the world. When a Fortune 500 company sponsors an educational program or throws its weight behind a small business, these guys might be responsible.
柯克·索德是Enso创意公司的联合创始人。他在学校学习了这个广告，以及之后那个柠檬广告。每个人都学过。柯克的公司擅长做让公司看起来关心世界的宣传活动。当财富500强公司赞助教育项目或支持小企业时，这些人可能负责。
Kirk is a sincere guy-- California crunchy optimistic about the world. He says it's not enough for VW to just apologize. They've got to use their folly to actively make the world better. Even before that, Kirk suggests opening up VW to some kind of third party.
柯克是一个真诚的人——加州那种对世界充满乐观的人。他说大众仅仅道歉是不够的。他们必须利用他们的愚蠢来积极地让世界变得更好。甚至在那之前，柯克建议对某个第三方开放大众。
You know, an investigative documentarian group, like a Frontline or an Alex Gibney who can come in with the charge of discovering what happens in a company that actually leads to this type of gross infraction.
你知道，一个调查纪录片小组，比如《前线》或亚历克斯·吉布尼，他们可以带着发现公司内部导致这种严重违规行为的真相的任务进来。
Kirk went ahead and made a promo for this imaginary documentary.
柯克继续为这个虚构的纪录片制作了一个预告片。
A new series from Alex Gibney, the director of The Smartest Guys in the Room , Coming Clean , Inside Volkswagen.
来自《房间里最聪明的人》、《洗清》、《走进大众》导演亚历克斯·吉布尼的新系列。
My most urgent task is to win back trust.
我最紧迫的任务是赢回信任。
This is the story of one of the largest frauds in history, the struggle of an iconic auto company to reinvent itself.
这是历史上最大的欺诈案之一的故事，一家标志性汽车公司重塑自我的斗争。
In today's advertising world, you might call this sponsored content, journalism style reckoning funded by Volkswagen.
在今天的广告世界中，你可能称这为赞助内容，由大众资助的调查式清算。
With unprecedented and unlimited access from Volkswagen, we get to the bottom of what happened to learn from what went wrong so it will never happen again, and to create new standards for all business. Coming Clean, Inside Volkswagen.
通过大众汽车前所未有且无限制的访问，我们要查明真相，从错误中学习，这样它就不会再发生，并为所有商业建立新标准。《洗清》，走进大众。
Next, we went to the ad agency M&C Saatchi, Maria Smith and James Bray. Saatchi works with all sorts of brands you've heard of-- Lexus, HBO. But Maria and James in particular focus on companies that are like underdogs in the market-- Yahoo, Uggs for men. And like other ad people I talked to, they're like, aw, Volkswagen.
接下来，我们去了M&C Saatchi广告公司，玛丽亚·史密斯和詹姆斯·布雷。Saatchi与你听说过的各种品牌合作——雷克萨斯、HBO。但玛丽亚和詹姆斯特别关注像市场上“失败者”一样的公司——雅虎、Uggs男鞋。和其他我交谈过的广告人一样，他们像说，噢，大众。
Da, da, da. Do you remember that? Just really nice little slices of life.
嗒，嗒，嗒。你记得那个吗？真是非常美妙的生活片段。
Their advice to Volkswagen is also pretty somber.
他们给大众的建议也相当沉重。
Just shut up. Just be quiet. Stop making excuses. And just start listening to the conversations that are happening out there.
闭嘴。安静点。停止找借口。开始倾听外面正在发生的对话。
Volkswagen can't speak, Saatchi says. No one would believe them anyway. Maria and James think you've got to crowd source the fix. Build a website. Let people vote on how VW can atone for their sins. For instance, plant 100,000 trees, or fund research to fix the ozone.
大众不能说话，Saatchi说。反正没人会相信他们。玛丽亚和詹姆斯认为你必须众包解决方案。建立一个网站。让人们投票决定大众如何为他们的罪孽赎罪。例如，种植10万棵树，或资助臭氧修复研究。
Imagine if a company like Volkswagen let you decide its fate, not lawyers or legislators, not politicians or lobbyists. You, drivers and passengers, environmentalists, mothers, fans, skeptics, anyone who's listening to this right now, everyone who feels betrayed.
想象一下如果像大众这样的公司让你决定它的命运，而不是律师或立法者，不是政客或游说者。你，司机和乘客，环保主义者，母亲，粉丝，怀疑论者，任何现在正在听这个的人，每一个感到被背叛的人。
Advertising has changed, these guys say. Today, it basically means jumping into what's already happening in social media and being part of that conversation, whatever it is.
广告已经改变了，这些人说。今天，它基本上意味着跳进社交媒体中已经发生的事情，并成为那个对话的一部分，无论是什么。
You'll hear this a lot, but brands are no longer what brands say they are. Whatever those people are out there saying about your brand is what you are. So this idea was to actually embrace that.
你会经常听到这个，但品牌不再是品牌所说的。外面的人对你的品牌说什么，你就是什么。所以这个想法实际上是拥抱它。
I've got to say, like, the internet is so scary. People could be so mean to them. Do you think that you might be, like, throwing this company to the wolves?
我必须说，比如，互联网太可怕了。人们对他们会很刻薄。你认为你可能会把这家公司扔给狼群吗？
Yes. Did they deserve to be? Yes. For a company that's willing to be thrown to the wolves like that, suddenly we all find them approachable again.
是的。他们值得吗？是的。对于一个愿意被扔给狼群的公司，突然我们都觉得他们再次容易接近了。
So you think even watching them get beat up--
所以你认为即使看着他们被打——
I don't think our intention is to get them beat up. I think it'll be smarter than that. I think the way we can filter suggestions out, we can make sure of that. But we also don't want to sugarcoat it, you know?
我不认为我们的意图是让他们被打。我觉得会比那更聪明。我认为我们过滤建议的方式，我们可以确保这一点。但我们也不想粉饰它，你知道？
It's what you'd do if you really wanted to make things better. That's why we're doing it. We want to make Volkswagen better. So make your voice heard at makeitbettervw.com. You've seen us at our worst. Now tell us with your vote how we can live up to our best. You vote. We'll listen.
如果你真的想让事情变得更好，你就会这样做。这就是我们这样做的原因。我们想让大众变得更好。所以请在makeitbettervw.com发表你的意见。你见过我们最糟糕的样子。现在用你的投票告诉我们如何才能达到我们最好的状态。你投票。我们会倾听。
All the ad agencies I talked to said that in order to get credibility back, Volkswagen first has to make something that is not a car, like a documentary, a code of ethics, or a website, some sort of grand gesture, like this idea from our last ad guy, Rich Silverstein from Goodby, Silverstein, and Partners, the agency who made Got Milk.
所有我交谈过的广告公司都说，为了找回信誉，大众首先必须制造不是汽车的东西，比如纪录片、道德准则或网站，某种宏伟的姿态，比如我们最后一位广告人，Goodby, Silverstein and Partners的里奇·西尔弗斯坦的想法，他是那个制作了“Got Milk”的公司。
People come to advertising agencies when they're desperate. They don't have an answer. So why don't you coat it with some honey?
人们在绝望时会来广告公司。他们没有答案。所以为什么不用蜂蜜涂抹它？
And you just tried to think of the most amount of honey you possibly could.
你只是试图想出你能想到的尽可能多的蜂蜜。
I wanted to pour that honey all over that diesel engine.
我想把蜂蜜倒在那个柴油发动机上。
Here's the honey. Move the VW headquarters to Detroit, the bleeding heart of the American auto industry. Then run an ad that's big and splashy and unapologetically American.
这是蜂蜜。把大众总部搬到美国汽车工业的流血心脏——底特律。然后进行一场盛大、华丽且毫不掩饰的美式广告。
The entire cast of Hamilton would be walking down Eight Mile at night. It would be sexier. We'll wet the road down. It's always sexy when you do that.
《汉密尔顿》的整个卡司会在晚上走在八英里路上。它会更性感。我们会把路弄湿。当你那样做时，它总是很性感。
When the road is wet?
当路湿的时候？
When you shoot car commercials, you always wet the road down so it glistens. Come on. Anything looks better when it's glossy. And so you wet the road down, and they're shining. And they're walking towards us. And they're singing. And in the background, the beat of it will be sampled, we totally screwed up, actually from the CEO who said it.
当你拍摄汽车广告时，你总是把路弄湿，让它闪闪发光。拜托。任何东西湿了看起来都更好。所以你把路弄湿，它们在闪耀。它们朝着我们走来。它们在唱歌。在背景中，节拍将被采样，我们完全搞砸了，实际上来自说这句话的首席执行官。
Volkswagen is sorry. We have totally screwed up.
大众汽车感到抱歉。我们完全搞砸了。
We the people's wagon, in order to build a more perfect engine, establish trust and ensure our company's tranquility, provide for our defense.
我们人民的马车，为了建立更完美的引擎，建立信任并确保我们公司的安宁，提供我们的防御。
The cast from Hamilton will be using the United States preamble. I'm thinking, anyway. We're working on this now. Jeez.
《汉密尔顿》的卡司将使用美国宪法序言。反正我是这么想的。我们现在正在研究这个。天哪。
--fictious emissions. We lied. They were 40% higher than the [BLEEP] we submitted. And we admit our decision was whack and lacking the vision, but at least we engineered that software with exquisite precision. Yo, I'm kidding and it's time for us--
——虚假的排放。我们撒谎了。它们比我们提交的[哔——]高出40%。而且我们承认我们的决定是荒谬的，缺乏愿景，但至少我们以精确的方式设计了那个软件。哟，我在开玩笑，是时候让我们——
And it will kind of go to the defense that if we come to America, we'll fix everything and you'll buy our cars again.
它会倾向于防御，如果我们来美国，我们会修复一切，你会再次购买我们的车。
Honestly, we've got a lot to offer the US economy. Imagine German engineers in the land of the free.
老实说，我们对美国经济有很多贡献。想象德国工程师在自由之地。
(GERMAN ACCENT) Wait. Are you suggesting we move the entire VW company to--
（德语口音）等一下。你是建议我们把整个大众公司搬到——
That's right. Detroit.
没错。底特律。
We reached out to Volkswagen and to the ad agency that has the Volkswagen account. They declined to talk to us. But I did run the three ad ideas by Brad and Rick, the guys who turned Jack in the Box around with their marketing campaign, to see which ad they think would work the best. Brad likes the voting one. He says millennials like being a part of things. And he's got a campaign like that in the works for his company Hardee's. Rick kind of likes the documentary idea because he thinks the most important thing to do now is an investigation.
我们联系了大众和拥有大众账户的广告公司。他们拒绝与我们交谈。但我确实把这三个广告想法告诉了布拉德和里克，那些用营销活动扭转杰克在盒子的家伙，看看他们认为哪个广告效果最好。布拉德喜欢投票的那个。他说千禧一代喜欢参与事情。他公司哈迪斯也有类似的活动在进行。里克有点喜欢纪录片想法，因为他认为现在最重要的事情是调查。
The people who did this are going to have to be identified and terminated publicly. Kurt and Gerhardt and Wilhelm and Heinrich, or whoever they are, they're going to have to be sacrificed because Volkswagen needs to live on.
做这件事的人必须被识别并公开解雇。库尔特和格哈特，威廉和海因里希，或者他们是谁，他们必须被牺牲，因为大众必须继续生存。
And they have to move fast. Their brand is being defined by everybody else right now. Rick thinks they can't be off the air for more than a couple months. This is no time to think small.
而且他们必须快。他们的品牌现在正被其他人所定义。里克认为他们不能离线超过几个月。现在不是想小的时候。
Zoe Chace.
佐伊·蔡斯。
[MUSIC - "WHAT CAN I SAY AFTER I SAY I'M SORRY?" BY DINAH WASHINGTON]
[音乐 - “在我道歉之后我能说什么？”，由黛娜·华盛顿演唱]
Well, our program was produced today by Jonathan Menjivar with Sean Cole, Neil Drumming, Stephanie Foo, Chana Joffe-Walt, Miki Meek, Brian Reed, Robyn Semien, Alissa Shipp, and Nancy Updike. Our editor is Joel Lovell. Julie Snyder is our editorial consultant. Production help from Lily Sullivan. Seth Lind is our operations director. Emily Condon's our production manager. Elise Bergerson's our business operations manager. Elna Baker scouts stories for our show. Kimberly Henderson is our office coordinator. Research help today from Michelle Harris and Christopher Swetala. Music help from Damien Graef and Rob Geddis.
嗯，我们的节目今天由乔纳森·门吉瓦尔制作，肖恩·科尔、尼尔·德拉明、斯蒂芬妮·富、查娜·乔夫-沃尔特、米基·米克、布莱恩·里德、罗宾·塞米恩、阿丽莎·希普和南希·厄普代克参与。我们的编辑是乔尔·洛弗尔。朱莉·斯奈德是我们的编辑顾问。莉莉·沙利文协助制作。赛斯·林德是我们的运营总监。艾米丽·康登是我们的制作经理。埃莉斯·伯格森是我们的业务运营经理。埃尔纳·贝克为我们的节目搜寻故事。金伯利·亨德森是我们的办公室协调员。米歇尔·哈里斯和克里斯托弗·斯威塔拉协助今日研究。达米安·格拉夫和罗布·格迪斯协助音乐。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[鸣谢]
Our website, thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks as always to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia. You know, whenever we go out and get drinks, he always says to me, you talk enough on the radio. But here--
我们的网站，thisamericanlife.org。《美国生活》由PRX，公共广播交易所交付给公共广播电台。一如既往地感谢我们节目的联合创始人，托雷·马拉蒂亚先生。你知道，每当我们出去喝饮料时，他总是对我说，你在广播里说得够多了。但在这里——
Just shut up. Just be quiet.
闭嘴。安静点。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带回更多《美国生活》的故事。
[MUSIC - "WHAT CAN I SAY AFTER I SAY I'M SORRY?" BY DINAH WASHINGTON]
[音乐 - “在我道歉之后我能说什么？”，由黛娜·华盛顿演唱]